well I'm in therapy right now for the
first time that I'm really like actively
excited about therapy I like to look
forward to it everyone should be therapy
for me a relationship is what catalyzed
the necessity of said therapy and the
reflection of how much how disconnected
from all of myself that I've been
largely like childhood bits
self-abanding I guess I could say and a
lot of like young boy even like baby
statues of myself within myself where
it's kind of like Frozen like vision of
your inner child is like very statuesque
like little boy yeah well the statues in
the sense that it's it's like aspects of
myself Frozen in time because at some
point in time I didn't have the
resources or the capacity to address it
and I think that's the definition of
trauma and Trauma is one of those words
that's words that gets tossed around a
lot particularly if you live in a place
like Southern California uh or or Austin
for that matter I historically have had
somewhat of an allergy of sorts to
different buzzwords like that doing the
doing the work
trauma you know re-parenting inner inner
child
and then you you get involved and you're
like oh my God this is this is this is
actually a thing
holy [__] why am I crying right now
having having very clear visuals like
psychedelic level visuals not
psychedelic like sacred geometry
spiraling out you know lizards crawling
up my my chest or anything but but
psychedelic in the sense of just very
Vivid visuals of um almost more clear
than psychedelics I would say of myself
um as a baby
and uh feeling feeling like lonely
feeling alone uh and feeling
afraid to love and afraid to open myself
up to love because I don't trust love
because I'm afraid that I will be hurt
like one of the visuals I've had is my
parents in kind of like a statuesque
type form uh almost like two chess
pieces like a king and queen and looking
away from me but like wanting to look
back but not not knowing how or not no
yeah they didn't have the tools they
didn't have the tools and so they so
they were and are still in a lot of ways
um
maybe lack resources or perhaps afraid
in some way or just calloused over it in
some aspects of like deep authenticity
with their own access to intimacy and
trusting of Love worse and then so
within that
your parents love you to the max degree
that they can yep and their their hurt
people and they're lovely people and
they're beautiful people and they're
they're all of the things but a part of
of that most people also are a little
hurt
and that's not everyone some people
might have completely cleared their
baggage of the past and their ancestry
and all of that no I don't know they
could it could it could exist I'm just
not barring that out as an impossibility
okay maybe there's some like bodhisattva
figures out there that's like no we
really really I've really unpacked the
[__] like there is no more [__] to
unpack there is nothing left underneath
tree yeah my my feeling is if a person
was in that orientation I don't know
that they would hold a body anymore
which gets a little out there oh my God
that's exactly the truth no I totally
agree I yes I mean through like
psychedelics and seeing certain things
like understanding that this is not real
and we agree to this and part of me also
has said like I wonder if certain things
are just inherent with this experience
of being a human and if you didn't buy
into these sort of constructs and have
these polarity Dynamics I wonder if
you'd even be here because when you know
that it's not real or you don't buy into
the the game like I really truly wonder
if you could hold form
yeah you might not need to I mean that's
the belief system
Western culture generally has a bit of
dis-ease around the concept of death
you know it's like really sad and it's
like devastating and it's a shame and
it's a travesty and it's a question mark
and it's a lot of that I don't think
there's a there's not a lot of of
definition around death as being
something that's really beautiful or
something that's that's really like
um
at least as beautiful as life you know
or as birth I was gonna ask what you
thought the percentage
of well-being is attributed to if you
were to divide up a hundred percent of
physical
versus emotional mental
like how much of what how would you
divide that up I don't know that it's
tough to differentiate a percentage
because I think that they are congruent
so you could make the body be fit like
physically fit right but sometimes for
example a person might be really
flexible but they might carry a massive
amount of tension somewhere in the body
right or they might be really strong or
like any of the things they might seem
like in really great shape but
oftentimes what that is I would fall
into this category they're they're
really brilliant at compensating and
they've they've oftentimes what looks
like the cover of muscle and fitness or
you know you might see like the rock or
somebody like that and you see that like
wow he's jacked and awesome and better
than me and like nothing could be wrong
in his life like look at that you know
and so I think that it's it's easy to
get and I don't know the rock so you
know he might be in this bodhisattva
category but nothing it's very easy to
get confused by just physical largeness
or chiseledness or something of the
source you man you just want bigger
muscles all the time it's always more
yeah for a girl bigger butt or no better
ways to hip ratio give you a smaller ass
I want a smaller oh that's good good for
you I love that buck in the Norms of the
day I would say I fall into category of
like a a really good compensator and so
an example of compensation in the
physical body would be a person that
maybe like they pull their shoulders
back they puff their chest out and then
from the time if they did like a like a
high school yearbook photo be like wow
they look pretty good like they've
pulled it all back big chest big strong
shoulders but physically posturally what
that that will do if you haven't
integrated that through the whole body
is you'll just end up tipping the pelvis
forward too much and go into hyper
lordosis and you know you might have
your feet end up going a little
externally and into pronation and you
just don't see it in the yearbook photo
so you don't see the part that that
people are looking right at and so a lot
of us are focusing on what do people see
and what do I see in a mirror and that's
fine
and it will it will burble up and it
will manifest itself as something I just
had Gabor mate on my my podcast just
like a week ago or that episode just
came out
um and he he's he goes really deep into
the relationship of like anger towards
one's self or anger in general
swallowing one's anger as opposed to
being able to like process and release
and that potentially manifesting itself
into something where the body begins to
you know like attack itself or like if
there's maybe some kernel of self-hatred
uh things of the sort the whole feel is
called
psychoneuroendocrinology people are
interested in going deeper into any of
that stuff Peter Levine is a great
resource awaken the tiger within Bessel
Vander calc uh is really good as well
the body keeps the score
yeah all those are really great
resources I have like more of a footing
in is I think the way that expresses
itself in an orthopedic way and also
just in body language
you know so if a person really feels
calm they feel safe they feel supported
they feel loved they feel fulfilled they
feel like ah like this moment like I
like this
you'll notice probably they're not going
to front and puff the their chest out in
like a prideful way they'll just allow
their shoulders to relax
you'll notice the tone of their voice
will probably start to be a little bit
more a little lower a little slower a
little like you'll notice their
breathing patterns will be more geared
towards a long relaxing exhalation it's
really easy for them to
oh
you know so and there you'll notice
their Vision might be less myopically
focused you know less like a shark get
stuff done Predator prey type
relationship and you're sorry let me
look away yeah right exactly and your
your eyes are continuous with your
central nervous system and their
neurological tissue it's like it is your
brain
and so all of these our senses are all
interrelated with our our thoughts
feelings and physiological expression
and so we have bought the idea that you
know you're Danica Patrick I'm Aaron
Alexander I'm uh this is my profession
this is my personality this is a car I
drive this is this is who I am you're
also an animal you know also you know
like like this this looks like mammalian
reptilian old million year old creature
conspiracy I'm not a reptilian yeah
whatever you're also maybe Spirit right
you're also you're also maybe a mother
maybe a father maybe you know maybe a
son maybe you're also hurt you're also
like you're so many things yeah
yeah but but we for ease and convenience
we kind of put ourselves into a package
for easier Pro easier processing you
know but you can just when you start to
look at the body language of a person I
think you see a lot of honesty come out
and it's less story and more just ah
here you are like your jaw is
chronically tense your muscles around
your neck are clamped down all the time
your diaphragm is chronically contracted
you're not able to take a full
exhalation like you're blocked from
exhaling
exhalation is tied into the
parasympathetic nervous system
so perhaps you don't feel safe to Exhale
where did you learn that maybe it was
something you learned before you even
had words
or not maybe it's something you learn
when you're 15 maybe so so it becomes
you know the the emotional aspect of the
self it just is congruent with the
physical expression
so can you separate those in a sense
like obviously you're probably not
taught like oh your exhale is your
parasympathetic and this is how you I
mean there's more thought more more
narrative around around breath work
these days but are you saying that you
can also you can come at it from the
other perspective meaning I feel like
it's probably an Adaptive sort of thing
when you you're tense because for some
reason you needed to be yeah program
that way something happened in childhood
where your environment
conditioned you to adapt that way so can
you then now come at it from the other
perspective of going like okay this is
how you get out of being in sympathetic
mode to drop into parasympathetic with
these with these um modalities that
shift your pattern yeah yeah it's not
probably adaptive it is adaptive yeah
it's great like it's so cool like the
body is so smart and the body is is so
honest yeah and it's so beautiful yeah
and we don't really listen to it
collectively
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen